y seguimos con nuestra serie sobre los
recicladores hoy vamos a san salvador
donde el reciclaje se convirtió en una
oportunidad de trabajo para jóvenes
salvadoreños y así alejarse de la
violencia de las pandillas este
reportaje hace parte de la serie de
publicaciones de resultado de la beca de
producción periodística sobre reciclaje
inclusivo y ejecutaba con el apoyo de la
fundación gao y la actitud de red el
informe es de claudia chicas
y dedicarse al reciclaje para estos
jóvenes que trabajan en un centro de
acopio de desechos en la capital de el
salvador representa una oportunidad
digna para pagar sus estudios y tener un
mejor futuro de vida para mí sería sacar
una diaria
allí era lo que
es lo que es
sólo que haya en diferente forma
en sueños
como la vida de aves
ya que es muy diferente
según datos del banco mundial la pobreza
ha ido disminuyendo en estos últimos
años en el salvador pero todavía los
jóvenes salvadoreños sufren de la falta
de oportunidades laborales y algunos
caen en la violencia de las pandillas
jóvenes como rodrigo encuentran en el
reciclaje una forma de vivir legal y
alejada de esa violencia
así como para nosotros los jóvenes es
algo complicado pero como ahí también
depende de la persona de lo que anda
haciendo así como nosotros nosotros no
andamos así en cosas ilícitas entonces
no tenemos que preocuparnos si nos sale
uno no sale no si no sale bueno dios nos
protege porque él sabe lo que andamos
haciendo con trabajo digno en 2020 tras
13 años de lucha entró en vigor una ley
integral de gestión de desechos sólidos
la nueva ley podría formalizar entre
3000 y 5000 recolectores también abrirá
un camino más en la formalidad para
rodrigo michelle y sus compañeros